et
on va plus loin avec à mes côtés
aujourd'hui anne nivat journaliste
indépendante bonjour anne rappel le
titre de votre dernier ouvrage il vient
de paraître à la france 2 face c'est aux
éditions fayard on va voir couverture
qui devrait normalement ça fait chier
voilà la france 2 face aux côtés des
français qu'on n'entend jamais ça fait
deux fois qu'on les entend avec vous
puisque déjà en 2017 vous étiez à
l'essai laisse filtrer voilà l écoute de
ces français face à vous virginie herz
qui a présenté actuelle sur l'antenne de
france 24 bonjour virginie
emmanuel macron et donc à moscou
aujourd'hui lady à l entame de son tête
à tête avec vladimir poutine il espère
amorcer une désescalade se dit
raisonnablement optimiste
déterminé et lucide voilà pour lui du
côté de vladimir poutine en revanche dès
la semaine dernière à il l'a dit il
souhaite aller au fond des choses avec
emmanuel macron ces croix au fond des
choses elle n'y va pour vladimir poutine
bon je ne suis pas dans la tête devenir
poutine qui d'ailleurs se fait attendre
puisque on est tous là suspendu à ses
lèvres ça fait quand même quatre heures
qu'ils sont ensemble et je crois que
c'est quelque chose qu'ils aiment
particulièrement vladimir poutine
aller au fond des choses ça veut dire
montrer finalement vous savez duty n'est
jamais tant heureux que quand ils voient
la faiblesse de son adversaire donc là
pour le moment il sent que en europe il
sait que ça n'est plus longue et la
merkel que c'est
emmanuel macron qui donc finalement
prend beaucoup plus de place en même
temps defacto c'est avec les états unis
que vladimir poutine discute tout le
monde le sait c'est à dire la raison
pour laquelle olafsen le nouveau
chancelier allemand est à washington
pendant qu'on parle là et c'est sa façon
de
disons ne pas déplaire continuer à jouir
de cette espèce de bras de fer qu'il est
en train d'entamer avec nous c'est à
dire que l'aïe prend il est plutôt dans
le positif disons venir où dit on va
voir ce qui va en sortir mais je
n'oublie pas qu'il ya quelques jours
lavrov son ministre des affaires
étrangères a dit absolument l' inverse
c'est à dire il a dit nous on parle avec
washington est sous-entendu la france
l'union européenne franchement vous
apporter peu pour nous ça n'est pas ce
qu'il a dit mais c'est ce qu'on pouvait
comprendre emmanuel macron dans la
position qu'avait eu nicolas sarkozy on
s'en souvient à la fin des années 2000
avec à l'époque c'était la géorgie qui
avait on s'en souvient d'ailleurs obtenu
via sa médiation et d'éviter en tout cas
une guerre c'est également ce que peut
obtenir à emmanuel macron il a vraiment
un objectif sérieux concret à à retirer
de cette visite ou bien ça va prendre
beaucoup plus de temps alors il est
quand même prudemment optimiste emmanuel
macron a dit qu'il n'y a pas de victoire
de court terme à attendre l'idée c'est
que il a envie de tenter le coup de
parler en tête à tête avec le vladimir
poutine qui l'a reçu déjà deux fois en
grande pompe à versailles on s'en
rappelle à brégançon également ça a été
d'ailleurs très polémique à ce moment là
il risque d'être attaqué emmanuel macron
de complaisance complaisance
effectivement de complaisance mais ce
qui peut gagner c'est du temps c'est du
temps c'est à dire que pendant qu'on
discute et bien a priori on évite
l'escaladent cole escalade se
poursuivent et juste pour vous dire sur
votre question précédente sur le fond
des choses le fond des choses à mon avis
c'est pour la veille la dîmière poutine
de restaurer la puissance russe c'est
sous quelle forme ça passe par revoir
vraiment les alliances qui se sont noués
au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale certainement en tout cas il ya
un dossier qui lui tient à coeur c'est
l'ukraine il a dit à plusieurs reprises
pour lui le peuple ukrainien et le
peuple russes ne font qu'un mais au-delà
de ça son obsession c'est l'effondrement
de l'urss a mené à l'effondrement de la
russie en tout cas à marginaliser la
russie sur la scène internationale et il
veut remettre la russie au centre des
relations internationales ça veut dire
être considérée comme une grande
puissance ça veut dire parler
directement avec washington et donc
créer et aussi cette sphère d'influencé
russe et se glacis géopolitiques autour
de ses frontières
conserver surtout le conserver du côté
de washington on joue l'urgence parce
que on lundi qu'un la russie disposerait
déjà de 70 % les trois quarts du
dispositif nécessaire pour une invasion
de l'ukraine dont on promet qu'en deux
jours l'armée russe parviendrait à kiev
et à déloger les autorités ukrainiennes
ce à quoi d'ailleurs les ukrainiens
répondent à ils dénoncent des prévisions
d'apocalypse ils ne comprennent pas que
les américains soit aussi inquiet pour
leur propre sort à eux les ukrainiens ce
cas une situation un peu paradoxale on y
va non mais c'est on ait envie côté
américain je ne sais pas si on joue du
côté américain en tout cas on se fait
peur on se fait peur et disons que ces
informations qui viennent des agences
américaines sont beaucoup plus abrupte
et sur un ton qu'on ne connaît auquel on
n'est pas du tout habitués par rapport à
la diplomatie mondiale global qui est
celle justement de joe biden des uns et
des autres mais ça ça n'est pas pour
déplaire à vladimir poutine une fois de
plus parce que vladimir poutine
aujourd'hui
ne tout en ne mettant pas jusqu'à
présent ses menaces à exécution
se plaît à ce que toute la planète
devises sur le fait que d'après ce que
les images satellites américaines disent
ils seraient en mesure d'avancer jusqu'à
kiev en 48 heures donc
en fait tout ça passe un petit peu par
dessus le cren et je crois que c'est
très important ça serait ce qui va se
passer demain quand emmanuel macron va
se rendre voir le président ukrainien
zelensky et qu'ensuite ils iront à
berlin parler avec olaf scholz et
également avec le président polonais
parce que ça c'est la grande maîtrise si
vous voulez je pense de de la diplomatie
européenne du jeu européen d' emmanuel
macron emmanuel macron
à beaucoup d'audace parce qu'il a autant
à gagner qu'à perdre dans ce qu'il est
en train de faire là deux mois des
élections présidentielles dans son
propre pays et à essayer de montrer que
finalement ce qui compte c'est
l'existence
d'une architecture de sécurité de
l'union européenne qui coûte finalement
celle de ou de washington donc là on est
un petit peu et on joue pas du tout le
même jour que les américains ils
auraient intérêt bladi à poutine à
offrir ce succès aux européennes pour
chaud surtout il faut dire lui aussi
d'une situation à un moment où il va
bien falloir qu'il se découvre qu'on
voit s'il s'agissait de bluff ou si au
contraire il est prêt à une invasion
dont on imagine bien qu'elle n'a pas que
des avantages pour lui a priori les
européens via des meilleures poutines
n'en a cure mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est que les européens quand même pour
la première fois on dit toujours les
européens sont divisés sur tous les
sujets et notamment sur l'ukraine avec
avec la position à adopter par rapport à
la dîmière poutine là les européens et
aussi les états unis sous quand même on
font front commun là tout à l'heure où
la de bayda aux états unis déclaré après
avoir rencontré la ministre allemand des
affaires étrangères que il ya un front
commun est effectivement là vladimir
poutine se sent peut-être est peut-être
un petit peu aculé parce que du côté
occidental
il n'y a quand même une réponse tu es là
on se sent
tout petit peu avec les états baltes
les trois états baltes qui ne sont pas
des cas qui font partie de l'europe mais
peu liaison nice tout à fait justement
le même point de vue que celui de la
france de l'allemagne et c'est parce que
eux justement ils le manifestent ils
l'expriment plus ils sont davantage
tourné vers les américains pour leur
sécurité donc ça c'est aussi un défi
mais ce n'est pas un défi nouveau c'est
le grain des grands défis de l'union
européenne des 27 oui reste à voir
maintenant effectivement comment va se
dénouer cette crise vous pensez que les
européens et les états unis peuvent
camper sur leur position pas
d'engagement sur l'avenir de l'otan se
laisse la possibilité d'un élargissement
à qui le souhaitent non je
je ne sais pas ce que je pense là on est
véritablement face à une trop même très
très grave crise donc si emmanuel macron
n'est peut-être pas capables tout seul
là à moscou et demain à kiev de la règle
et puisque tout le monde dit qu'il n'a
pas de baguette magique ça montre quand
même que il faut réfléchir à ce que
signifie pour la russie ce que la russie
entend par une menace à sa frontière et
se prend la psychologie russe on l'a pas
fait intégrée c'est-à-dire reconnaître
si emmanuel macron réussissait à faire
admettre aux russes que l'otan que
l'occident reconnaît d'une certaine
façon que la russie se sent
blessée est mécontente de ce qui
pourrait se passer à sa frontière avec
l'élargissement de l'otan ça serait déjà
peut-être un début d escalade peut-être
de la considération en tout cas oui de
l'accident fou comme un air de guerre
civile n'ont pas de guerre civile
d'ailleurs mais plutôt d'anarchie à
ottawa à la capitale administrative du
canada en proie à la colère des
chauffeurs routiers exaspérés par les
mesures sanitaires la situation est hors
de contrôle dit le maire écouter
quand vous avez des milliers de
manifestants contre des centaines de
policiers nous sommes en infériorité
numérique et nous devons nous assurer
que l'ordre ramener dans notre ville il
ya des personnes âgées qui ne peuvent
pas sortir de jeunes enfants qui ne
peuvent pas dormir à cause des feux
d'artifice les manifestants font preuve
d'une insensibilité totale envers leurs
concitoyens
on parle des manifestations ici en
france mais là on a vraiment un maire
qui déclare l'état d'urgence et qui
décrit une situation finalement qui
échappe totalement au contrôle des
pouvoirs publics voilà quoi peut mener
l'obligation vaccinale
oui mais on va plus loin la cc comme
avec les gilet jaune ça commençait par
un sujet particulier puis ensuite sam ça
arrive à une fronde vis-à-vis de du
gouvernement là c'est justin trudeau qui
lui-même visé qui d'ailleurs et on ne
sait pas où puisqu'il a été je crois
positif aux bleus vide et que lui et sa
famille sont 160 ailleurs mais moi je
trouve que ce qui ce qui est important
là c'est le fait que le chef de la
police lui-même est dit que la situation
était hors de contrôle ce qui a mené le
maire à cette nuit ce matin ici en
europe de dire que que la ville était en
état de siège ça c'est j'ai totalement
inédits comme situation ce qui est clair
c'est que
ça cristallise les mesures vaccinale
cristallise le mécontentement on l'a vu
en europe on le voit là de façon extrême
ce qui est intéressant c'est que ça
cristallise et sa agrège des mouvements
de colère par ailleurs donc on pourrait
s'en faire le parallèle avec les gilet
jaune ce qui est intéressant aussi
d'après notamment radio canada qui a un
petit peu travaillé sur la question
c'est que parmi les leaders aussi de ces
de cette contestation on a les proches
des complotistes on a un leader qui est
proche de ce qu'on dirait l'extrême
droite en tout cas raciste qui qui veut
défendre la race blanche très clairement
et sa agrège beaucoup de phénomènes
montraient qu'ils n'ont pas grand chose
à voir les uns les autres la soie du
capitole mais oui mais on y avait un
drapeau d'ailleurs je crois que celui
dont vous parlez avait rebondi serge
launay aussi impliqué dedans en tout cas
ce qui est intéressant c'est que y
compris des syndicats de camionneurs au
québec essayent de se distancier en
disant nous on n'a pas passé de consigne
particulière donc fait ils sont dépassés
ils sont dépassés et eu également sont
dépassés et s'il semblerait que en tout
cas ce mouvement autant les gilet jaune
avait inspiré outre atlantique un
mouvement qui a pas énormément primé
autant ce mouvement inspire en ce moment
en france en tout cas un mouvement aussi
de protestation qui commence parmi les
camionneurs mais qui va aussi on l'a vu
aux pays bas arrivé en ont mais on est
dans une ère la protestation plus rien
et légitime plus aucune parole ne
légitime et il y a là une espèce de
grand écart entre no no no grande nos
démocraties qui proclame la liberté
d'expression pour tout le monde et de
l'autre côté la nécessité de maintenir
l'ordre et on va voir si les canadiens
en tout cas la capitale fédérale il
parvient merci beaucoup et on y va
c'était on va plus loin avec également
virginie hertz